Shoshana is with us in Michigan
hey Shauna how are you hi Dave thanks
for taking my call
sure what's up well where my husband and
I are currently going through your PSP
you a class we are going to be certain
step 7 lesson 7 but taking the class has
really motive motivated me to I guess
find an occupation that people little
more so we can get through our debt a
lot faster and where I'm currently at
right now they offer a program for a
free college and it's for associate's
degree I've decided to you know get into
that take that next step and it's gonna
be business management focusing on
Finance of all things and but I guess my
question is I know I'll complete this
it's free so books and everything they
it's good to be online I don't want to
pay for any of that but I will probably
want to continue on to a bachelor's and
just for that next two years how would I
be able to do that for free and if
there's scholarships for adults for
college there are but they're they're
fewer then there are four kiddos
[Music]
non-traditional students they call us
because we're not 22 yeah so you're
you're in Michigan so southeast okay and
so what is the four-year that's near you
well the online class is out of Ohio the
transfers before you're in your area yes
I have I have two colleges right in
Adrienne but there's like there's a
Community College ray and Adrienne as
well and they all they do not offer
four-year degrees so I could train and
just on the road for me really for that
college so I could transfer to that to
continue it on thank you all for earlier
but yet the Jackson does yes there's
that community that likely we're
would finish yes because it would be a
community college so it'd be cheaper I
don't really care about the name of you
know the fancy colleges so I would like
to end they really do focus on business
management as well oh they haven't you
know then you want to make sure your
online school will transfer and get full
credit at the new at Jackson yeah are
you putting all this effort even though
doesn't cost you anything you don't want
to have all the effort and then go well
we don't really take their classes as
credit you got to start over
or you have to mom or you have to move
to some other cities in order to finish
your four-year no we don't do all that
so we want to make sure that the hand
off the baton hand off is available and
is solid so yeah I think the other thing
by the time you finish this associates
will you be out of debt into your house
other than your home yes that's my
husband said pretty much the way we're
going right now
I will probably be out of our non
mortgage debt before I even complete my
associates yeah that's what I mean you
could cashflow the last two years have
you had to yes everything would just get
the house gone so and then invest it and
then I have two daughters once a
sophomore once a freshman so it would be
stepping right into the college savings
so push that in there yeah you're going
to cashflow that as well probably
because you haven't started that yet
right no unfortunately not okay so we
got a lot of scholarships to find for
you and the kids we've got a lot of work
to do and some planning and just
projecting out I would definitely do the
associates even if you had a little gap
between when you finish the associates
and when you continued and get knocked
out the other two years you might have
to take a breath because you might be
paying for that sophomores freshman year
yeah you know if you're having to pay
for it out of pocket if you can't find
some scholarships for non-traditional
but you can also spend some T IME on
that it's good it's time well spent and
hit Anthony O'Neill's website we got ten
thousand scholarships on those
scholarships too and they're not all for
traditional so there's something for
everybody there's just not ten thousand
for you
there's 10,000 for ya know the others
but if you could find even a list that
had three or four hundred on it
and you apply for all of them and got
three or four of them it'd be a big help
right oh yes definitely yes yeah so that
that's kind of large numbers is how you
do when you're attacking the
scholarships thing you get turned down
for most of them you get a few of them
but it's 10 grand
you know my one I plan on getting
Anthony's book when we get it in the
budget
Rama send you I'll send you one oh thank
you so much sure we can do that so you
guys we appreciate you being in
Financial Peace University and I
appreciate that you're really doing all
this planning now I love it last time
last thing I want to ask you because I
think I heard this in the way you're
structuring your sentences but I just
want to say it out loud you're getting
this four-year degree in business why
well business is I'm just saying picked
business management because I figure it
would be a lot of more options
especially as a general business manager
for healthcare being that that's good to
be in and a need so that was my option
and right now I'm only 14 an hour wage
so I wanted to you know further mine and
I know I can do so much more for myself
and with my education so that's kind of
why I think if I were you I would also
narrow that down and say I want to do X
Y or Z right now you're saying I want to
do the whole alphabet and the and the
business degree will allow me to do any
any letter I want to do and it's a
little too broad I want you to have
something a little bit more refined that
you're aiming at with this you're
generally saying if I get an education
I'll make more if I get a degree in
business it's applicable a lot of places
and that's more of a shotgun I want to
narrow this in a little bit because you
could end up getting this degree in
getting nothing out of it as a result if
you don't have a defined intentional
goal that you're going after or a series
of defined intentional goals it doesn't
be one thing but I'd like to be doing X
or Y or Z that pays $80,000 a year when
I finish this I want to finish this
study track and I have thought that
through have looked at that job category
and it's not just generally I'd like to
make more money in this gen
is an applicable thing it's not a bad
place to start the discussion not a good
reason to spend four years of your life
going after it though because you may
find out that nothing happens as a
result of it if you don't have good
clear goals and a good clear target that
is an actual possible job or career
field that pays considerably more than
you make now so you're starting the
discussion right you're not going to end
it well if you don't take it all the way
through good question hold on Madison
will pick up will get you a copy of
Anthony O'Neill's book very well done
that's fun that you took a class at your
church from Financial Peace University
and it makes you re-evaluate your
education goals and your career goals
ding ding almost like we're doing our
job I love it